[Music]
based on a Stephen King novel stanley
kibrik threw in the trash comes an
iconic piece of horror cinema here's
Johnny
that was probably scary before it got
parodied to death
[Music]
yes cloudy don't The Shining sit back
way back for two and a half hours of
Kubrick's signature style that's either
a masterclass and building tension or
kinda boring in a film that's largely
made out of the same three shots
characters staring at the camera
characters pulling a crazy phase
or characters wandering around
but hey everything feels creepy when you
put that score under it
oh it's just you Wednesday journey to
the Overlook an empty hotel on top of an
Indian burial ground with a long history
of murderer
so like a nice motel 6 cozy and settle
in with the winter caretaker Jack nickel
tour ins who in the book is a loving
family man who slowly goes mad over the
course of the season as the dark secrets
of the Overlook are revealed except in
this movie he never really liked his
family why you should eat in your
breakfast he goes crazy over the course
of about a week I'm not gonna hurt you
I'm just gonna bash your brains II had
the dark secrets of the Overlook we're
part of the job interview who killed his
family with the max Wow
but Jack made some time is space too
right damn it and he'll take all the
dark paranormal energy he can get if it
lets him procrastinate on his novel even
more hmm I could finish this chapter or
I could kill my whole family then I'll
write two chapters honest I swear Jack's
not alone in this haunted house there
Shelley Duvall's Wendy a woman living in
growing fear of her abuser Stanley
Kubrick little Danny Torrance who shows
you don't need fancy CGI to pull a golem
chair me and dick hallorann a cook with
The Shining a psychic talent that's kind
of useless if he couldn't see this
coming
I got an axe to the chest after flying
coach from Miami to Denver
that's like dying twice experience this
complex and baffling masterpiece that
could be an allegory for anything the
treatment of Native Americans alcoholism
fate versus free will alienation
writer's block
Theseus in the Minotaur the Illuminati
it's all a dream kubert's confession for
faking the moon landing MKULTRA there in
hell injects the devil the Holocaust the
patriarchy the destruction of Kubrick's
old neighborhood a warning about staying
in the back to long or the importance of
regular snowcat maintenance there we go
that's the one they cracked the code you
guys we can stop overthinking it
check your snowcat so immerse yourself
in horror that breaks all the rules of
today no big shock moments no elaborate
backstories or explanations and no
unstoppable monsters just a sad dad
who's killed by the wrong choice of
jacket imagine this came out today 100%
chance this trailer has a weird
minor-key version of lettuce No
[Music]
starring cut my wife into pieces this is
a ghost resort
sir this is a windy my little Tony
Friendship is Magic
groundskeeper chilly blood in an
elevator Hotel Motel homicide in the
Grady vines the Grady bunch for a con
1980 and don't stay in the bath too long
or you wrinkled up so I married an axe
murderer
they change so much from the book they
really should have just let Stephen King
have complete control if you want
something done right you want to do it
yourself
cocaine is a hell of a drug hey screen
junkies we made a feature-length
documentary about Galaxy Quest called
never surrender it's actually really
good honest your commander is on click
on the left to learn more or click on
the right to see our latest episode of
power levels the only place to watch
Jamie Foxx find a Pokemon that's not on
the dark web all work and no play make
Homer something something I told you
never to call me on this wall this is an
unlisted wall